hey youtubers it's Charlie so the BBC
just announced info on when they're
gonna post the next trailer for the 50th
anniversary episode as well as two new
Doctor Who mini episodes I've also got
some really big announcements to make
about special Doctor Who videos that I'm
making with BBC and Nerdist for the 50th
anniversary episode so be sure to
subscribe to get all the info so first
off let's start off with the new trail
it's going to be posting November 15th
so I know a lot of you weren't able to
make it to comic-con so most people have
not seen any actual footage from the
50th anniversary episode so this new
trailer that they're going to be posting
on the fifteenth will actually have
footage from the 50th anniversary
episode so here's the details the clip
is going to air on November 15th at
seven-thirty p.m. on BBC one during a
special children in need 2013 special
don't worry if you don't get the BBC or
you live in another country they'll be
posting it online on their YouTube
channel right after just like they did
with the last clip so now let's talk
about the mini episodes so both of these
many episodes will be appearing on the
50th anniversary DVD they won't be
appearing online so you have to buy the
DVD to get them the first one is called
the night of the doctor it will pick up
right after the events of the 50th
anniversary episode and it will star
Matt Smith and David Tennant it'll be
about seven minutes long so it'll be a
fully self-contained small episode the
second mini episode is called the last
day and currently we really don't know
anything about who's going to be in it
other than Matt Smith or what it's going
to be about it's only about four minutes
long so it might not be a full mini
episode just like the night of the
doctor don't worry if you can't buy them
or you don't get to see them i'll be
doing a full breakdown and review of
those mini episodes once they start
selling them on December second i'll be
posting my review of the actual 50th
anniversary episode on the twenty-third
right after the episode airs so you'll
be able to see that much much sooner but
here's details on all the special things
that I've been invited to do with
Nerdist and the BBC for the actual 50th
anniversary episode so first things
first we will be doing a very special
live stream with Nerdist and the BBC on
the actual day it'll start in the hours
leading up to the 50th anniversary
episode on the twenty-third don't worry
i'll be posting a lot more information
about the actual live stream when we get
closer second the BBC has invited me to
make a bunch of special Doctor Who
videos in the weeks leading up to the
50th anniversary episode so the actual
17th november seventeenth is the
beginning of Doctor Who week on YouTube
think of it is like a special doctor who
take over of all of YouTube I'll be
making a very special video that week
that will post on the BBC's Doctor Who
channel be sure to subscribe to get that
in the next couple of weeks i'll be
doing about eight special Doctor Who
videos leading up to the 50th
anniversary episode just to help
distinguish them from all the other
videos I do for the other shows I'll
just be adding a special doctor who
booked at the bottom here that you be
able to see so if you have any questions
about the Doctor Who videos that I'm
doing or any questions about the 50th
anniversary episode the mini episodes or
the Christmas special or even series 8
please leave them in the comments and
we'll discuss off' i seriously guys this
is going to be such an amazing month
doctor who is taking over the world
please subscribe and help join me in
celebrating Doctor Who seriously we're
going right from the 50th anniversary
episode to a month-long celebration of
the beginning of Peter Capaldi's rain
and Doctor Who and the end of Matt
Smith's rant it's going to be so amazing
in the meantime you can click here to
get all of my videos for the 50th
anniversary episode and you can click
here to get all my other Doctor Who
videos seriously it's going to be
amazing guys thank you so much for
watching high five see you tomorrow
you